despite the many challenges that go into
buying a home and the cost let alone
hispanics are one of the groups that
continue to drive home ownership up
across the nation a new report in fact
shows nevada's latino population
accounted for more than 47 percent of
our growth in just the last 10 years
hector mejia reporting live this morning
with a little bit more on this report
hector good morning to you
good morning guys and we've learned the
increase in homeownership was in line
with the increase in population growth
for hispanics here in nevada and we've
also learned the pandemic put a greater
emphasis on buying a home even though
this is one of the most difficult
housing markets for first-time buyers
and it's definitely a hard time to be a
home buyer right now especially with
today's market the national association
of hispanic real estate professionals
says home ownership has been training
upward for hispanics at least over the
last 10 years here in nevada with the
home shortage and rise in prices many
families are going for the entry-level
type of housing say between 250 and 325
thousand dollars
that's something that is um you know
sustainable for them through their work
through the income they make
and we find that there are very little
options so a lot of
a lot of hispanic homeowners as really
any first-time home buyer right now is
really just having to kind of
stay in the sidelines watch the market
and really present an offer so that the
competition is high
more projections say that by 2040 u.s
hispanics will make up 70 percent of all
first-time buyers across the us as more
first and second generation hispanics
are striving to become homeowners and
stop renting and still ahead of the next
half hour we'll go over the persistent
challenges still affecting the housing
market right now when it comes to this
demographic reporting live hector mejia
live local now